A group of Latino lawmakers
in Connecticut are calling
for a statewide ban of the term Latinx
from official government documents.
They say the gender neutral
alternative to Latino or Latina is a term
that is offensive to Connecticut's
large Puerto Rican population.
Joining us
now is more Democratic
Connecticut state
representative
Heraldo Reyes, Jr, the bill's sponsor.
Thank you for your time.
First, just explain to us, why do you
this term is offensive
Well, thank you very much
for the question.
So I am one of the sponsors.
I want to clarify that
there are six sponsors on the bill
and Representative
Rosario representing
Gonzalez, representing
Candelaria, Representative Sanchez
and Representative Santiago and myself
are all Puerto Rican
Latino elected officials
here in the state of Connecticut
who all find the term offensive.
And it's a term that we believe is
unnecessary because the Spanish language,
which is 50 plus years old,
already identifies
male, female and neutral
and neutral.
So we don't believe that it's necessary.
If you don't like the word Latino
or Latina,
you can use Latin or or Latino,
which is what the proper turn is for
neutral gender.
Hmm.
Well, here's what the actor and comedian
John Leguizamo says about it.
He likes the term.
Here's why he says, I love it.
I think it's about time.
I think it gets rid of the machismo
that is not natural to our language,
but got used by our language
to promote male dominance.
I love now that it's Latin.
It's it's all inclusive, and I love that.
So basically, he's saying that
that using Latino is gendered
because it's the male
oh, it's the male adjective.
And that's correct.
And and I respect John Leguizamo.
I understand his
his his brilliance,
and I respect his work.
But I will beg to differ him
on that particular segment
that whether it's in my term, in my
by my thinking, it is offensive
and I'll give an example.
So I've had the opportunity
to travel
across these great United States
to speak with many Latino legislators
and the majority of legislators
in the state,
in the United States of America
that are of Latino descent, are Mexican.
And most of the Mexican
American legislators
find it very offensive
and we've had this conversation
with legislators
from Texas,
California, Arizona,
Massachusetts, Rhode Island,
New York,
New Jersey, and obviously Connecticut.
So my my my point being here
is that the majority, the high 96
97% of the Latinos that speak Spanish
find it offensive
there is a small percentage of people
that, again,
this is not to be divisive in any way,
and this is not to put off anybody.
This is simply a term
that we do not want to see in government
and in higher education.
It's not a ban of the word.
It's a ban of the word
and use
it as it is related to government,
official business
So you talked about the percentage of
Latinos who, you know, who
do not use this word
or do not like the word.
There's a Pew study that shows that most
Latino adults
have never even heard of the term Latin.
76% have not heard of it.
Another 20% do not use it.
Only 3%, according to this Pew study,
use the term Latinx.
So you've got this legislation now.
What's the possibility,
the probability that it gets passed
Well, thank you for the question.
So there's there's a process
we will have.
Public
hearing is in general, administrative
committee right now,
and it's going through
committee screening.
What we what we are
hoping to get
is a public hearing very soon
because we definitely want
the input of the public.
Number one.
Number two,
it comes out of committee
and it goes to screening
and it has to pass
screening both in the majority
and the speaker's screening process.
Both sides,
the majority in the minority party.
Then when it passes that hurdle,
then it goes to either it's a House bill.
So it'll go to the House
of Representatives floor first.
If it passes there, then it goes to that.
The Senate,
if it passes
in, the governor can sign or veto it.
So that's the process.
All right,
Representative, for all the rest,
thanks for explaining your perspective.
Great to talk to you.
Thank you very much for having me.